this streamer has found a way to play
games with her mind finding success in
games like Elden ring Halo and track
Mania all without the use of a
controller and the best part it's not
just Perry that can do
[Music]
it mind control gaming is exactly as it
sounds it is gaming with your mind so in
my case I have an EEG that picks up my
brain activity and then I've just
translated that into pushing buttons on
a virtual controller an EEG or an
electroencephalogram which I've had to
spend a few weeks practicing how to say
is uh a bunch of electrodes that go on
your scalp and it picks up the
electromagnetic rain activity that comes
from your head it can look and see what
kind of activity is going on and if I've
trained it to recognize what this means
then it can look and see if you're doing
that for instance imagining something
coming towards you could make the
character attack in game something
lifting Dodge something sinking in water
to heal I can move the character by
tilting my head the kind of things that
you should say to me to get some brain
activity are anything that would elicit
a really strong emotion the best one
that I've seen so far is fear and
shock so when I'm playing a horror games
it lights up if if there's a jump scare
okay fear
so I don't what to say
um I'm embarrassed that that worked
that's not good
that's a bad sign that's a bad bad sign
ah okay I'm
running oh dear oh oh
okay right now I'm really really into
games like anything that's Dark Fantasy
RPG like Souls light games games that
are really difficult and punishing
because I think maybe that's just part
of my
personality
it took me about 6 months to make it
work the first time just to make it push
a button in a game and right now I'm on
10 months into the project and it's
still not perfect I may have missed the
turn the main obstacle though wasn't
building the controller or doing the
coding the main obstacle was getting the
mental commands to work so actually
thinking of what I should be visualizing
to record and I had to train them up for
about I think in total we're on 600
hours of of doing the same pattern over
and over again and telling the software
what to remember and that's just of the
visualizations I have now so there were
loads of other iterations that didn't
work because they were too similar to
each other or they just didn't make any
sense or I was there was one where I was
imagining pulling something down from
the sky and then I realized about 3
hours into doing it that that's not
going to work because then I'm not
looking at the monitor I'm not looking
at the
game but my first moment where I thought
there's no way this is possible I can't
believe that this is happening this must
be a fluke this must be a mistake was
the first time that it worked so I was
running around with the character Steve
in Minecraft and it was the first ever
visualization it was pushing a block
forward and I wanted him to swing his
fist in mine and then I did it and then
he did it and it was just the wildest
thing I was absolutely blown away and I
thought this is such a far out idea
based on something that I've never tried
before and as far as I'm aware very few
people have and it worked and I had to
do it over and over again not to test it
not to make sure not to get it better
but just to believe that that was that
that actually was me doing it and not
some random wild error I felt
absolutely mind blown I guess part of
the
[Music]
P are you ready to have your mind blown
no let's try this let's calibrate this
bad boy so you're literally going to
visualize something you see is heavy it
can be the cube that you s scen and
you're going to imagine pushing it
Forward
okay
oh I'm definitely losing focus all right
right
no
rubbish do you know what it is is now
I'm like can't perform so you
immediately start thinking about
[Music]
it I saw it move but I didn't know I I
thought that was like I don't know if
that was a
problem that is insane I'm now in Elden
ring and I'm going to try and cast a
spell through pushing an imaginary block
I'm already thinking about a little bit
right here we
go yes I didn't think I was going to get
it as
well
yes that's I can feel it honestly you
feel so powerful
this is like when you first pick up a
video game and you do something
incredibly like rad like in skate you do
a kick flip with an analog stick and you
like discover a mechanic for the first
time and it's not like anything else
you've experienced in gaming this is
unbelievable the feeling is just
ridiculous but you also still unnerving
a little bit it used to give me a
headache at the beginning but that's
just from the headset itself the actual
process it requires a lot of focus and
energy but it doesn't hurt I don't know
how this is affected did my brain
properly but I have noticed that my
focus has improved a lot which as
someone with ADHD is really helped me
just do things day-to-day life when I'm
not gaming you kind of have to focus a
lot when you are trying to for example
defeat a boss in Elden ring because the
way that the mental commander
visualizations work is that you have to
think of the same thing every single
time in the exact same way so if you
deviate from that a little bit if you
think about something else then it just
won't work so when you have a boss
running towards you it can be really
difficult to focus on for example
sinking something and drinking a potion
but that's just practice and I think
that's why it has really helped improve
my focus in general because being able
to block that out and go internal in
terms of what you're imagining is a
really really useful skill I
think
the technology is out there to be able
to control things with your mind they're
controlling loads of Prosthetics with it
but no one's really applied it to gaming
and by getting the technology out there
my my thought process was that one it
would be a really cool thing to do but
also that it might raise a little bit
awareness for what's possible and a lot
of the time when we think about
accessibility issues we think about what
is the bare necessities but gaming and
being involved with what your friends
are doing and being involved with
entertainment and media is also a
necessity so if we can do something with
this uh at some point in time with
enough funding and development then that
would be really cool okay I feel like
I'm getting am I like hilariously sweaty
no oh my God I'm so sweat do you want
some powder no it's all right we'll
embrace it and there's the controller
your brain
activity my brain activity is smaller
than
yours whoa C something's wrong with
me it's
full